grazie buon pomeriggio a tutti io sono
chiara vi parlerò di quella parola che
probabilmente qualcuno di voi conoscerà
ma magari no e cercherò di farvi capire
che cosa nel modo più semplice possibile
crowdfunding scusate prevedevo questo
momento e dal panico come la governate
voi
ok andate su home home schermo a schermo
intero
ok scusate yes
ok questa è la definizione strettamente
di wikipedia
diciamo che tecnicamente crowdfunding a
un sistema di microcredito cioè voi
avete un'idea e potete raccogliere i
soldi per realizzarla non in grosse
cifre banche o istituzioni ma
semplicemente facendo appello alla
colletta è fondamentalmente all'aiuto di
tutti è una parola composta non ha
intenzione funzionare non c'è verso
scusate ok
ok io nel frattempo continuo è una
parola composta da due parole crowd la
massa le persone e funding che è il
finanziamento ovviamente i soldi andiamo
avanti ci esistono circa 400 piattaforme
di crowdfunding nel mondo non è un
fenomeno soltanto italiano ovviamente è
fondamentalmente si dividono in tre
modelli il primo modello è il modello
cosiddetto reward based cioè si basa lo
scambio si basa sulla corresponsione di
una ricompensa la donazione che si fa è
a tutti gli effetti una donazione libera
a cui in cambio il progettista colui che
ha avuto l'idea fa corrispondere un
prodotto o un emozione un'esperienza
collegata all'idea che lui sta cercando
di portare avanti il secondo modello è
il cosiddetto acuiti based corrisponde
tecnicamente un investimento vero e
proprio io ti do una piccola cifra
inverso su di te è un domani se la tua
azienda funzionerà avrò in cambio un
ritorno sull'utile il terzo modello è il
cosiddetto social lending cioè
tecnicamente un vero e proprio prestito
che consente poi al progettista di
restituire la cifra che ha avuto dalla
massa delle persone con un tasso
particolarmente agevolato
io vi parlo del reward based che è
quello che in questo momento stiamo
cercando di fare in italia
fondamentalmente si colloca all
intersezione di queste tre buone
pratiche
la prima la storia per creare un
progetto di crowd funding bisogna
principalmente raccontare una storia una
storia che appassioni le persone
la si può raccontare se andiamo avanti
grazie con due mezzi un testo è un video
due parole velocissime il testo deve
essere il più possibile coinvolgente il
crowdfunding è fatto di persone che
parlano ad altre persone con me ne sto
parlando a voi quindi se io vi racconto
la mia idea
per prima cosa devo cercare di
appassionarvi devo essere trasparente
cioè devo spiegare come userò i fondi e
magari devo cercare di dirvi grazie una
cosa che non è banale perché molti
progettisti si scordano di farlo l'altro
aspetto il video il video che può essere
fatto nel modo più semplice possibile
anzi meno business meno uno già speso se
uno ci ha speso anche 0 e si è messo di
fronte a una webcam e si è raccontato è
anche
meglio l'importante è far vedere il
prodotto l'idea di cui si sta parlando a
metterci la faccia e anche lì a
raccontare la propria storia
il secondo punto è lo scambio per
l'appunto le ricompense vi dicevo un
prodotto un'emozione che cosa vuol dire
facciamo l'esempio di una compagnia
teatrale sul territorio che vuole
produrre il proprio spettacolo ha
bisogno di 5 mila euro può dare in
cambio come ricompensa sia un biglietto
per andare a vedere lo spettacolo
ovviamente sia far vedere lo spettacolo
dietro le quinte una cosa che uno
spettatore comune non potrebbe comprare
e se a un vero appassionato in questo
modo può sapere di sostenere con la
compagnia prima ancora che realizzi lo
spettacolo è di avere in cambio un dono
unico oppure addirittura chi sa di
andare a cena con la troupe per esempio
terzo punto fondamentale la cooperazione
fabio ci ha parlato benissimo della
working on line e off line
l'idea è che tu sei il primo
ambasciatore della tua idea e chiunque
ti sostenga chi può venire dietro può
parlare di te e può fare da eco e
amplificare la tua idea può e lo deve
fare perché ti darà una mano esattamente
come se ti desse dei soldi e se ti da
anche i soldi è meglio quindi questo è
la generazione di valore è un prodotto
un qualsiasi prodotto culturale
imprenditoriale che trova la sua strada
grazie al potere della community e come
vedete non genera soltanto del
finanziamento ma genera soprattutto
fiducia coinvolgimento partecipazione ed
emozioni è così che si crea il senso di
una comunità e la si dirige a
partecipare a lavorare insieme al
creatore a un progetto creativo
chiudo raccontandovi molto velocemente
due storie
la prima chiara chiara è una designer è
una grafica lei chiedeva 5.000 euro
andiamo avanti per realizzare la sua
idea
lei è la caratteristica che lei una
designer vegana disegna magliette a tema
vegano lei lavorava per un datore di
lavoro faceva la grafica la video maker
a tempo perso che lei rappresentato così
un gioco monster perché ha detto che
quelle sono le anime dei dipendenti che
lui sfruttava è un certo punto ha deciso
chi se ne frega mi voglio mettere da
sola fa queste magliette in cotone eco
compatibile lavorato insomma con
principi etici e ci abbina tutto
lavorato su con
inchiostri anche quindi che non
deturpano l'ambiente e ci abbina un
messaggio che è un messaggio vegan
questo è uno dei tanti disegni tra il
grottesco e il divertente che lei
realizza lei raccolto 5mila euro e l'ha
saputo fare benissimo community vegani
non sono molti in italia non sono molti
neanche nel mondo in realtà e hanno una
rete di relazioni molto forti per cui
lei sfruttando il passaparola tra i blog
chiedeva semplicemente dei fondi per
poter crearsi un piccolo shop online e
far diventare quella che è sempre stata
una passione una fuga dallo sfruttamento
del lavoro che lei subiva è una nuova
opportunità di fare una piccolissima
impresa e ce l'ha fatta
il secondo è un progetto che è
attualmente in finanziamento che è
fattelo 1.840 euro raccolti la tassiamo
2002 stamani sui 5000 manca ancora quasi
un mese
andiamo avanti loro sono federico mattia
antonio e daniele designer comunicatori
grafici hanno creato questo progetto che
adesso vi faccio vedere è una lampada
che si chiama fattelo qual è il
principio anzi fatto del progetto
lampada si chiama 0 1 qual è il
principio questa è una lampada open
source che cosa vuol dire che voi potete
andare sul sito scaricare questa
fustella non ve lo posso far vedere
tutta aperta
prendere un cartone a casa che vi avanza
il cartone della pizza siete statali che
avete comprato una sedia quello che
volete ritagliarlo seguendo questo
disegno e realizzare fisicamente questa
lampada andando poi semplicemente a
comprare un piccolo led e un cavo e
agganciarla
io vi faccio anche vedere che funziona
perché se no non ci si crede
l'importante mi hanno detto raccomando
raccomandati di dire che la lampada non
deve essere incandescenza perché sono al
programma si crea quindi se volete
potete andare sul loro sito e scaricarla
e farvela da soli altrimenti loro come
questa ve la forniscono vela realizzano
loro il loro obiettivo di raccogliere
5.000 euro per aprire la loro impresa
tutti e quattro hanno un altro lavoro ma
questo il loro sogno hanno altri
progetti nel cassetto
il principio è che ecologica che è
riciclabile che ci puoi fare quello che
vuoi
ho un amico che mi ha detto me la farò
tutto a disegnare dalla mia bambina e
poi la metterò in ufficio e sarà unica e
fatta in quel modo ce l'ha però soltanto
io
questo è loro
sogno e questo è il sogno che noi stiamo
cercando di raccontare grazie a loro
concludo velocissimamente perché so di
aver perso il tempo dicendo una cosa il
crowdfunding non è la pentola d'oro alla
fine dell'arcobaleno
diffidate di chi vi dice questo mi piace
più pensare che crea fanno in sia una
bacchetta magica che ha letto un po di
harry potter che la bacchetta magica e
potente quanto e potente il mago che la
sa usare qualcuno sannino prima ha detto
che in italia ci sono più soldi che
buone idee ma forse nel mondo perfetto
se volete dimostrare che nel mondo ci
sono più soldi che buone idee e queste
idee le idee di eppela del mio progetto
e delle altre piattaforme di
crowdfunding vi piacciono
andate a casa condividete idee andatevi
a guardare i progetti sceglietene uno
sceglietene più d'uno e sostenetelo solo
così questo metodo si affermerà grazie